I don't think there's really a lot of
evidence yet in people that we can
increase lifespan by affecting stem
cells and actually it's important to
realize that as we age the number of
functional stem cells we have declines
and you know who knows it may be that
some of the disorders that we have in
the aging population are a consequence
of running out of stem cells and being
unable to replenish our own tissues and
organs and that may well be true of the
brain for sure and I and there's some
evidence that that's also true in other
organs so I think it may be the loss of
stem cells that is part of the aging
population it's a very good question if
we if we could restore stem cells
particularly in some of those critical
organs would we increase lifespan and
would we even want to I think it's a
it's a philosophical as well as a
scientific question and we don't have
the answer tonight